Доброго дня шановні учасники
всеукраїнського тижня професійної освіти
сьогодні в рамках тижня ми проводимо
вебінар від професійного стандарту до
кваліфікаційного центру їсть вітальним
словом Я представляю
директорку директорату професійної
освіти Міністерства освіти і науки
України панну пані Ірину Шулик прошу вас
пані Ірина до слова
Добрий день шановні колеги ми вже
перетнули лінію екватора тижня
професійно-технічної освіти який
проводиться в рамках року європейського
року навичок і я із задоволенням так би
мовити продовжую сьогоднішній день ми
його назвали день роботодавців перша
половина дня була у знаменована круглим
столом з представниками роботодавців і
закладів професійної освіти Можливо
хтось з вас там вже був бо я бачу
знайомі обличчя хто ще не був Ви маєте
таку можливість перейти на YouTube канал
мон і
передивитись якщо ви також зацікавлені у
можливостях співпраці з роботодавцями і
презентації кращих практик але
розвиваючи цю тему Ми сьогодні Щиро
дякуємо національному агентству
кваліфікації за те що долучилися до
тижня професійно-технічної освіти і
сьогодні проводити
власне вебінар який більш детально
розкриває можливості на сьогодні закладі
професійної освіти щодо створення
кваліфікаційних центрів І власне
враховуючи тематику і того що ми
сьогодні будемо торкатися в питанні
розроблення професійних стандартів
зрозуміло нарешті буде пояснення
закладам професійної освіти А чому ми
такий фокус на сьогодні робимо на
професійні стандарти чому це є важливо і
власне як взаємопов'язані професійний
стандарт освітній стандарт і оцінювання
кваліфікації на виході який
власне
основний сенс в тому щоб оцінювання на
сьогодні яке відбувається переходило до
більш незалежні руки і в незалежній
формат від себе лишень Хочу додати ми ще
продовжуємо працювати
в багатьох випадках за освітньою
кваліфікаційними характеристиками і ми
знаємо кваліфікаційні характеристики
деякі з них тягнуться що з радянських
часів добре якщо свого часу вони були
переглянуті А якщо не були переглянуті
то тут питання до якості тих фахівців І
власне до переліку компетентностей
навичок Якими мають володіти на сьогодні
спеціалісти на ринку праці і від того
залежить подальша успішність кар'єрного
розвитку і взагалі самореалізації на
ринку праці кожного окремого українця чи
кожної окремої Українки саме тому я
думаю що ми сьогодні детально розглянемо
що таке професійний стандарт навіщо він
потрібен оскільки професійний стандарт є
основою для розроблення освітнього
стандарту і в подальшому освітньої
програми і ми поговоримо як здійснити
правильно цей перехід від професійної
стандартного до реалізації в системі
освіти і власне я
Якщо ви теж поділитеся досвідом як
успішно створити кваліфікаційний центр
проти кваліфікацію акредитацію
національному агентстві кваліфікації і
організувати роботу з незалежного
оцінювання не тільки кваліфікацію
формальній освіті А також ти
кваліфікації якісь здобуті шляхом
неформальної та інформальної освіти я
власне хочу побажати в нас сьогодні
присутнє
54 учасники і частина
наших гостей буде долучена на Ютубі я
власне всім вам бажаю сьогодні успішної
роботи і дійсно цікавого вебінару
Дякуємо пані Ірину дійсно сьогоднішній
захід досить є такий змістовним оскільки
назва самого заходу навіть говорить
правда пані рино яким чином ми від
професійного стандарту саме перейдемо до
кваліфікаційного центру оскільки для
того щоб кваліфікаційний центр
запустився має бути затверджений
професійний стандарт і вже на основі
затверджено професійно стандарту в якому
зазначається професійна кваліфікація і
буде створений кваліфікаційний центр
який саме буде займатися присвоєння
професійної кваліфікації дякую пані
Ірина
вітальне слово колеги з вашого дозволу
хотіла б ще зорієнтувати по часу який
нас Відведений для зазначеного заходу
наш захід орієнтовно тримати триватиме
одну годину і 30 хвилин Протягом цього
часу ви можете у вас буде можливість
прослухати дві презентації перша
презентація буде на тему професійний
стандарт як інструмент забезпечення
якості професійної освіти
зазначено презентацію буду представляти
я я її заступником голови Національного
агентства кваліфікації Акімова Людмила
Миколаївна друга наша презентація на
тему кваліфікаційні центри правовий
статус та окремі аспекти створення
доповідає в нас пані Ганна грязнік
заступник голови Національного агентства
кваліфікації
перед тим як ми розпочнемо презентацію
Шановні колеги хотіла звернути вашу
увагу що після двох презентацій буде
Відведений час для ваших питань де ви
можете задати питання І ми вже у вигляді
питання відповіді надамо вам на них
відповіді але Шановні колеги ми
розуміємо що якщо у вас зараз виникають
якісь питання ви можете їх ставити в
чаті і ми вже після завершення заходу
будемо мати сформований перелік питань
на якій буде вона давати відповіді
також звертаю вашу увагу на безпеку так
тобто про те що вже нам говорили на
початку щоразу отримання сигналу
повітряної тривоги ми будемо реагувати в
залежності від ступеня загрози так тобто
зараз безпека у нас пріоритеті А зараз я
б хотіла Шановні колеги попросити всіх
учасників закладу написати коротко своє
ім'я прізвище який освітній заклад ви
представляєте і з якого ви саме місце це
дасть нам можливість трошечки з вами
познайомитись тому Шановні колеги прошу
зараз в нас буде перша презентація
Зараз я їх хвилинку треба щоб я її
поширила і почнемо наш захід
колеги все видно Добре
так все видно
Добре Отже Шановні колеги
презентація професійний стандарт як
інструмент забезпечення якості
професійної освіти так Тобто ми
розуміємо що на якість професійної
освіти впливає багато чинників серед
одних чинників Або можна сказати серед
них факторів саме що стосується
підготовки професійної освіти відповідає
той чинник які ж професійний
кваліфікації зараз затребувані на ринку
праці так і Відповідно ми бачимо
впродовж починаючи з 2018 року в нас в
Україні починають з'являтися професійні
стандарти тому що саме 17-18 року були
затверджені два основних документи і за
допомогою яких професійні стандарти
розробляються але ми ж пам'ятаємо що ще
до
розвитку 17-го року в нас діяли один з
таких перших документів в якому
прописувалася вимоги як до працівника це
були кваліфікаційні характеристики Так
але ми розуміємо що вимоги часу
змінюються і саме на зміну тим вимогам
ринку праці яким зараз нас є в 2012 році
саме в законі України про
професійно-професійну технічну освіту
з'являється поняття таке як професійний
стандарт протягом тривалого часу воно
вдосконалювалося це поняття і вже в
законі України про освіту 2017 році було
зазначено що саме професійний стандарт
затверджений в установленому порядку він
установлює вимоги до компетентно вимоги
до компетентностей працівників що
слугують основою саме для формування
професійних кваліфікацій
тобто основна відмінність професійного
стандарту тому що він побудований на
компетентнісному підході і в нього
описується саме результати навчання які
є основою для освітніх стандартів на
першому слайді ви бачите саме
відмінності так
кваліфікаційної характеристики від
професійного стандарту так від
призначення до актуальності структури і
зв'язку з нрк так Оскільки ми бачимо
наскільки структура професійного
стандарту вона більш деталізована
розкриває компетентності проводить опис
трудових функцій через знання уміння
навички комунікації і відповідальність
та автономію тому що на основі тих
ключових моментів які будуть заложені в
професійному стандарті так буде освіта
розуміти і що саме освітня програма має
бути в основі просвіт в освітньої
програми також однією перевагою хотіли
би зазначити щодо актуальності
кваліфікаційної характеристики і
професійного стандарту як ми бачимо що
професійний стандарт він підлягає
перегляд так кожні 5 років Тобто ми
розуміємо якщо на ринку праці Виникають
нові вимоги до працівника то в
розробника який саме розробляє
відповідний
професійний стандарт є можливість внести
відповідні зміни що стосується
кваліфікаційних характеристик
перепрошують то ми бачимо що як і
замітила пані Ірина що вони були ще
кваліфікаційні характеристики в
Радянському Союзі і зараз ми бачимо що
вони не переглядаються так тобто вони
вже є
застарілими зв'язок з національною
рамкою кваліфікації він відслідковується
тільки в професійному стандарті
Отже що ми бачимо якими чином
професійні стандарти вони є основою для
освітніх стандартів та освітніх програм
тому що саме в професійному стандарті
прописується результати навчання на що
освітня програма зважає на це увагу тому
що саме зв'язок з результатами навчання
через професійні до освітніх стандартів
він є досить вагоми тому що при
формуванні при формуванні
перепрошу освітнього так стандартах
освітньої програми робиться акцент саме
на професійний стандарт він є основою
для наповнення освітньої програми і ми
бачимо Шановні колеги яка ж відмінність
так кваліфікаційних характеристик і
професійного стандарту
тобто
одне з ключових на щоб я хотіла так само
звернути увагу що стосується оцінювання
професійних кваліфікацій так тобто за
допомогою професійного стандарту ми
можемо оцінити ті результати навчання
які закладаються професійному стандарту
і ці результати навчання є основним для
освітніх програм
кваліфікаційному
кваліфікаційні характеристики немає
цього одного етапу тому коли
розробляється проект професійного
стандарту робиться великі акцент щоб
компетентності результати навчання були
записані таким чином щоб їх можна було
оцінити
що стосується
доступності так до кваліфікаційних
характеристик і професійних стандартів
на сайті національного кваліфікації
пізніше на своєму слайді я покажу є
реєстр кваліфікацій так в реєстрі
кваліфіка цьому місці знаходяться певні
колонки і де саме розміщуються
професійні стандарти тобто національна
агентство кваліфікації буде реєстр
кваліфікацій наповнює реєстр
професійними стандартами які
затверджуються розробниками І після того
як Вони внесені реєстр цей професійний
стандарт вступає як в дій
хотіла б вашу звернути увагу одним з
основних таких ключових і повноважень
національного агентства кваліфікації є
повноваження
стосовно координації з розроблення
професійних стандартів тому що ми
розробляємо та саме порядок розроблення
ведення в дію та перегляду професійних
стандартів і подаємо на затвердження До
кабінету міністрів України Національне
агентство кваліфікації також приймає
участь в інформаційному просторі так
методичного забезпе До речі розробника
тими необхідними матеріалами які йому
будуть слугувати 3
розроблені проекту професійного
стандарту Отже Шановні колеги декілька
таких ключових моментів наголосила на
тому Яка ж це таке відмінність цих
кваліфікаційних характеристик від
професійного стандарту і також звертаю
вашу увагу що саме 17 червня 2022 року
набув чинності закону України
2179-9 від 1 квітня 2022 року про
внесення змін до деяких законодавчих
актів України щодо функціямування
національної системи кваліфікації саме
зазначеним законом вносяться зміни до
кодексу законів України про працю також
до закону України про оплату праці
закону України про освіту та закону
України про зайнятість населення і саме
зазначеним законом передбачається
пріоритетність професійного стандарту по
відношенню до кваліфікаційної
характеристики так якщо
професійний стандарт відсутній за
відповідною професією то тоді до уваги
вже беруться відповідні кваліфікаційні
характеристики але зазначеним законом
надається перевага професійного
стандарту над кваліфікаційними
характеристиками
Шановні колеги які ж основні документи
які слугують
як допомозі для розробників професійний
стандарт перший основний документ він є
нормативний це порядок розроблення
введення в дію та перегляду професійних
стандартів ви бачите що він був
затверджений постановою Кабінету
Міністрів України в 2017 році за цим
посиланням ви можете зайти і
ознайомитися з відповідним
документом
зазначений документ були внесені зміни
так а саме 27 грудня 2022 року
постановою
14,53 були внесені зміни до порядку
розроблення ведення в дію та перегляду
професійних стандартів
одна з ключових змін що стосується
розроблення професійних стандартів що
саме в порядку було написано що
методичні рекомендації
схвалюються національним агентством
кваліфікацій і вони оприлюднюються на
офіційному вебсаті Тобто ви бачите на
слайді що саме 25 січня 2023 року
рішенням національного агентства
кваліфікації було схвалено методичні
рекомендації і за посиланням ви можете
зайти і ознайомитися з відповідним
документом тоді як
звертаю вашу увагу що саме порядок
розроблення ведення дії та перегляду
професійних стандартів Він встановлює
загальні вимоги до процедури розроблення
ведення в дію перегляду публічного
громадського обговорення професійного
стандарту і Щодо його затвердження то
методичні рекомендації щодо розроблення
професійних стандартів вони слугують
практичним роз'ясненням для розробників
і така методична допомога для тих хто
розробляє професійних стандартів щоб
вибудувати єдиний підход єдину таку
концепцію в процесі розроблення
відповідного професійного стандарту
також говорила вам про постанови 14-503
і в якій саме зазначалося був перехідний
період на основі цього перехідного
періоду професійні стандарти
розроблялися ще на основі методики яка
діяла і була затверджена в 2018 році
методика розроблення професійних
стандартів вона була затверджена на
Міністерства соціальної політики 2018
році і при внесенні змін в порядок
розроблення ведення дію та перегляду
професійних стандартів з розробників
професійних стандартів було три місяці
для того щоб розробляти професійні
стандарти за старою
структурою починаючи з 31 березня
професійні стандарти розробляються за
новою структурою яка зазначена в додатку
2 до порядку розроблення ведення в дію
та перегляду професійних стандартів Отже
Шановні колеги
переходимо до етапу саморозроблення
затвердження професійних стандартів яка
ж ключова роль представників освіти в
етапах які в етапах щодо розроблення
професійних стандартів Отже ви бачите на
слайді
ключові 9 етапів розроблення та
затвердження професійних стандартів
тобто на початковому етапі на першому
розробник тримає рішення про розроблення
проекту професійного стандарту це може
одноособово прийняти розробник що він
бажає розробляти або до нього
звертається юридична чи фізична особа
надає своє пропозиції обґрунтовує щодо
необхідності розроблення відповідного
проекту професійного стандарту тоді що
розробник подає заявку на розроблення
відповідного проекту професійного
стандарту вона надходить до агентства і
відбувається реєстрація
так агентство реєструє заявку
Відбувається
формування робочої групи підготовчий
процес і де щодо наповнення професійного
стандарту І після того як наповниться
професійний стандарт відбувається
проведення публічного громадського
обговорення відповідного проекту
професійного стандарт Тобто ми бачимо
колеги з 3 по 6 пункт Перепрошую ми
виділили такі кольором залили для того
щоб ви зрозуміли що саме на цих етапах
представники освіти можуть долучатися в
процес розроблення професійних
стандартів зараз пізніше я наголошу і
більш детальніше розкрию саме змістову
частину яким чином представники освіти
долучаються до розроблення професійних
стандартів 7 етап ми бачимо погодження
професійного стандарту з
репрезентативними всеукраїнськими
об'єднанням професі спілок на галузевому
рівні але звертаю вашу увагу якщо
професійний стандарт розробляється
негалузевою радою то обов'язково має
бути погоджений наступне проводиться
перевірка щодо дотримання вимог порядку
під час підготовки проекту професійного
стандарту перевірку проводять два
суб'єкти з 2021 року Національне
агентство кваліфікації і спільне
представницький орган сторони
роботодавців на національному рівні І на
9-му етапі затвердження професійного
стандарту так і відповідно до закону
який на початку наголосили 2179 так саме
зазначеним законом було внесено зміну що
затвердження професійних стандартів
зараз відбувається розробника тому що до
внесення змін в закон розробник
розробляли професійний стандарт надавали
на перевірку до двох інституцій І після
того проект професійного стандарту І що
нас затвердження до Міністерства
економіки тобто наразі в порядку існують
прописані такі ключові моменти яким
чином відбувається саме проект
розроблення і затвердження професійного
стандарту і саме зараз на даний час
розробники затверджують професійні
стандарти Отже переходимо перед тим як
перейти до більш детального Обговорення
та етапу щодо реєстрації заявки звертаю
вашу увагу що якісь зміни які були
внесені в 27 грудня 2022 року до порядку
розроблення ведення в дію та перегляду
професійних стандартів стосується також
тих проектів професійних стандартів які
містять інформацію з обмеженим доступом
зазначені проекти професійні стандартів
вони не підлягають публічному
громадському обговоренні і перевірка їх
проводиться згідно з дотриманням вимог
законодавства про інформацію з обмеженим
доступом двома членами агентства які
саме визначені ним Тобто це такі
ключовий момент раніше його не було в
порядку Зараз прописалося щодо тих
проектів професійних стандартів які
містять інформацію з обмеженим лісом
Отже Шановні колеги переходимо до етапу
реєстрації заяв Так я вже вам зазначала
про те що саме представники освіти
можуть долучатися до розробки
професійного стандарту коли до
Національного агентства кваліфікації
надійшло заявка що відповідний підрозділ
опрацьовує заявку дивиться чи немає
відповідної професійної заявки яка
затверджена раніше а внести нам перепро
реєстр кваліфікації або затверджено
професійного стандарту якщо немає
відбувається реєстрація професійної
заяви після цього Національне агентство
кваліфікації надсилає інформаційний лист
довідника до відома як розробника так і
Міністерство економіки Міністерство
цифрової трансформації держпраці також
надсилаємо до спільного представницького
органу репрезентативних Всеукраїнських
об'єднань профспілок на національному
рівні І до СБУ сторони роботодавця на
національному рівні І ви бачите жирним
виділено також до інших заінтересованих
суб'єктів в тому числі і Центральній і
виконавчий органи влади відповідно до їх
повноважень тому що щоб на цьому етапі
всі зацікавлені сторони які б хотіли
прийняти участь в розробці професійного
стандарту Вони мають розуміти що подана
заявка
позазначеному проекту професійного
стандарту і вони можуть долучитися до
робочої групи також колеги бувають такі
моменти що враховуючи навіть заручну
ситуацію яка в нас є країні що той
термін на який професійний стандарт було
відведено орієнтовний строк проведення
робіт
завершився але проект професійного
стандарту ще не розроблений тому
порядком і передбачається продовження
строку розроблення про стандарту або
скасування тобто розробник який подав
заявку вбачає за необхідність Або
можливо на ринку праці здавилися нові
професійні кваліфікації які є більш
затребувані і розробник може подати
заявку на іншу професійну кваліфікацію
вона розроблення професійного стандарту
яка зараз на даний час є більш актуальні
і тому ви бачите Шановні колеги що також
національне кваліфікація інформує за в
цей колбері для того щоб вони розуміли
яка ситуація з відповідною заявою
наступний такий ключовий етап щодо
формування робочої групи так тобто
дійсно велика
об'єм роботи для при формування
розроблені професійного стандарту на
формування складу робочих груп
обов'язково в порядку прописується хто
має бути в складі робочих груп ми бачимо
три ключових стихолдер це роботодавці їх
організація та об'єднання профспілки їх
організації та об'єднання і сфера освіта
так тобто тут вже освітяни залучаються
до розроблення проекту професійного
стандарту саме При формуванні робочої
групи за згодою ви бачите можуть також
долучатися як представники центра великі
місцевих органів виконавчої влади так і
інші фахівці за видом економічної
діяльності за яким саме розробляється
проект професійний стандарт якщо до вас
як до інституції звернулися
щодо внесення вас до складу робочої
групи так Це добре але ви маєте також
бажання саме самі виявити що ви хочете
працювати в складі робочої групи тому що
ви є експертом фахівцем зазначеність в
сфері економічної діяльності і ви маєте
на це право тому тоді ви звертаєтеся до
відповідного розробника з листом що
просимо вас що ви просите щоб вони вас
включили в склад робочої групи тому що
ми розуміємо чим більше в складі робочої
групи буде саме фахівців експертів
відповідної галузі тим професійний
стандарт він буде якісний і тому
освіти є ключовою в складі робочої групи
що стосується
формування галузевої рад так тому що ви
на слайді пам'ятаєте так що професійні
стандарти якщо розробляються розробником
вони подаються одразу до суб'єкта
перевірки або до Національного
кваліфікації або СБУ роботодавців
проходять перевірку і після перевірки
вони надсилають за розробнику вже на
затвердження
це в тому випадку коли професійний
стандарт розробляє галузева гра так
Тобто ви бачите що галузева рада з
розроблена професійних стандартів вона є
робочим органом що утворюється за
галузевої ознаки з метою розроблення
професійних стандартів до складу
галузевої ради ми бачимо входять
роботодавці Профспілкова сторона і
заклади зрозуміти так тобто весь спектр
широкий задіяний в складі робочої групи
але після того Вони одразу що надходять
до на перевірку до зазначених інституцій
тобто
звертаю вашу увагу що і в складі
галузевої ради Так обов'язково є
представники освіти які
при наповненні професійного стандарту
можуть надавати ті пропозиції саме до
змісту наповнення професійного стандарту
щодо підготовки наступного етапу
підготовки проекту професійного
стандарту так структура на яку я на
початку
нашого вебінару говорила що саме
структуру професійного стандарту вона
зазначається в додатку 2 до порядку
розроблення введення в дію та перегляду
професійних стандартів і ця структура
вона докорінно відрізняється від
попередньої структури
тому що ми розуміємо які зараз є виклики
на ринку праці і відповідно до тих
викликів які є на ринку праці була
оновлена структура професійного
стандарту обов'язково звертаю вашу увагу
що три розроблені професійні стандарту
всі члени робочої групи мають розуміти
що наповнення структури кожного розділу
підрозділу воно прописано методичних
рекомендаціях так тобто методичні
рекомендації вони такі є базису для
єдиного підходу де на прикладах
наводяться конкретно як заповнювати
кожний розділ чи табличку яка
зазначається в проекті професійного
стандарту Отже які основні яка ж основна
основні етапи розділи
структури професійного стандарту Так
отже ми бачимо 9 ключових розділів з
яких складається професійний стандарт ви
бачите що в нас розділ четвертий і
шостий за потреби так тому що ми
розуміємо що скорочення скорочення в
відповідному професійному стандарті є
доречним якщо він розробляється на певну
професію чи професійну кваліфікації де
досить багато буде скорочень і для
зменшення навіть об'єму професійного
стандарту доречно буде зазначити в
окремому розділі ці скорочення і тому
вони є за потреби якщо у вашому
професійному стандарті які Ви
розробляєте так на декілька професійних
кваліфікацій то розподіл трудових
функцій та на компетентності за
професійними стандартами ви Він має
місце якщо тільки одна один одна
професійна кваліфікація то ми розуміємо
що потреби в зазначеному розділі немає
тобто з 9
розділів які я зазначаються на слайді
всім вони є обов'язково Отже більш
детально можливо перейдемо зараз
саме до тих
розділів щодо їх наповнення для того щоб
ви зрозуміли яким же чином наповнюється
професійний стандарт Отже Шановні колеги
структура професійного стану Так отже
назва професійного стандарту а другий
розділ в нас загальні відомості про
професійний стандарт і В загальних
відомостях про професійний саме
розкривається мета діяльності за
професією мета діяльності за професією
Вона має зазначатися стисло лаконічно і
розкривати сутність відповідної професії
на якою розробляється відповідний проект
професійного стандарту
назву виду наступний підпун назва виду
видів економічної діяльності
секції групи
класу та іншого коду та їх Перепрошую та
їх коди згідно з ДК 009 20 10
класифікація видів економічної
діяльності Перепрошую забула тобто цей
підпункт в нас зазначається за потреби
так якщо професія або на групу професій
розробляється відповідний проект
професійного стандарту вона є наскрізною
Так вона входить до складу декількох
професій то не вимагається зазначати
Саме тут
КВЕДи відповідно виду економічної
діяльності
щодо третього підпункту Де зазначається
назва професії код підклас згідно уже
класифікатора професій звертаю вашу
увагу що саме
новим порядком саме змінами які були
внесені 27 грудня чи 22-го року
зазначається що перед тим як подати до
Національного агентства кваліфікації на
нову професію яка не зазначена в
класифікаторі професій розробник
інформує Міністерство економіки щодо
розроблення відповідного проекту
професійного стандарту так він сам
одноосібно визначає приналежність
зазначеної професії до відповідних
класифікаційних угруповань і вже коли
проінформувавши Міністерство економіки
Він подає відповідну заявку до
Національного агентства кваліфікат
національне кваліфікації що реєструє її
але якщо є певні
заперечення або можливість уточнення
відповідної назви нової то Міністерства
економіки спільно з розробником вони
комунікують для уточнення нової назви і
тоді вже якщо нова назва
відрізняється від попередньої
національної агенство кваліфікації
Перепрошую розробник інформує нас про
внесення змін до назви професійного
стандарту тобто обов'язково перед тим як
подати заявку на розроблення
професійного стандарту за новою
професією має обов'язково розробник
поінформувати Міністерство економіки що
стосується
наступного підпункту узагальнена назва
професії тобто якщо за потреби вбачаєте
необхідність вона також може бути
прописана або може бути відсутній і
також назва типових посад за потреби що
стосується 6 підпункту професійна
кваліфікація та її рівень згідно
національної рамкою кваліфікації так
тобто звертаю ваші уваги Шановні колеги
Що
попередніх професійних стандартах до
2022 року коли були внесені зміни до
зазначеного порядку
всі розробники не зазначали саме рівень
професійної кваліфікації не поєднували
його з рівнем національної рамки
кваліфікації зараз На даному етапі
це вагомий такий ключовий елемент де
обов'язково
розробники мають прописати і співставити
рівень професійної кваліфікації який він
вони закладають в професійному стандарті
зріви з рівнем нрк і саме тому в додатку
5 до методичних рекомендацій
зазначаються
методичні рекомендації щодо
співставлення
професійної кваліфікації з лівим
НВК там є три способи яким чином можна
співставити відповідну постійно
кваліфікацію тому звертаю вашу увагу що
коли буде користуватися методичним
рекомендаціями в додатку досить багато є
такий ключових елементів які вам будуть
слугувати три розробці професійного
стандарту наступне ми бачимо підпод
назва документу що саме підтверджує
професійну кваліфікацію так Шановні
колеги ви отримали саме основні такі
документи які підтверджують професійну
кваліфікацію відповідної особи тут
виділене бачення виділили жирне
Перепрошую шрифтом свідоцтво про
присвоєння підвищення робітничої
кваліфікації так з додатком Тобто це
поняття нас ототожнюється саме з
професійної кваліфікації
наступний розділ третій - це здобуття
професійної кваліфікації та професійний
розвиток Отже
в цьому розділі прописується саме умовою
яким чином відбувається присвоєння та
підтвердження професійної кваліфікації
мінімальний рівень освіти для робітничих
професій це не є обов'язковим тобто тут
прописується за потреби галузь знань або
спеціалізація та або спеціалізація для
професій що потребують вищої освіти за
потреби стаж роботи також на потреби і
інші
професійний розвиток він в себе вбачає
наступні компоненти це присвоєння
наступної професійної кваліфікації або
без присвоєння наступної професійної
кваліфікації для вдосконалення
підтримання для чого це ж необхідно для
вдосконалення підтримання професійної
кваліфікації так в тому числі шляхом
здобуття нових додаткових
компетентностей і для підтвердження
наявної професійної кваліфікації одним з
таким ключових елементів це є опис
трудових функцій тому що як на початку
нашого вебінару зазначала що саме
компетентності що саме професійні
стандарти вони побудовані на
компетентнісному підході І що саме
професійних стандартах розкриваються
результати навчання через знання уміння
навички комунікацію відповідальність та
автономії яким же чином має бути
прописана компетентність так тобто назва
компетентності Вона може відповідати нас
від трудової трудової дії також крімком
трудових дій можуть об'єднуватися вони в
одну компетентність
компетентність Вона має бути сформована
досить чі стисну та зрозуміло на основі
якої на основі чого надається все-таки
професійна компетентність
професійна компетентність Вона
починається із стверджуваного дієслово
так тобто здати
розробляти відповідну готувати захищати
Тобто ми стверджуємо так на початку
прописуємо компетентність і має вона
бути основний такий акцент також роблю
бути зрозумілою зокрема у разі її
використання надалі під час розроблення
саме освітньої програми так тому що як
ми говорили про те що професійний
стандарт він є сам основою базису для
наповнення як освітньої програми так і
для наповнення стандарту освіти
також звертаю вашу увагу що
розділі опис трудових функцій є другий
пункт для де професійної кваліфікації не
нижче 5 рівня національної рамки
кваліфікації зазначається саме цифра два
компетентність раніше в порядку це не
передбачалося але ми розуміємо що зараз
ринок праці змінюється новими
технологіями і тому все-таки цифрової
компетентністю має оволодіти відповідний
працівник який буде працювати на певному
робочому місці також прописується
трудові дії предмет та предмети і засоби
праці обладнання устаткування які
необхідні для виконання
на робочому місці Але ми бачимо що вони
за потреби тобто дивлячись яка
дивлячись
професійний стандарт розробляється на
яку
паперу діяльності
щодо Шановні колеги наступного
наповнення професійного стандарту тут
уже є велику увагу не буду звертати ви
бачите тут основні розділи стосуються
наповнення професійного стандарту хто
розробляв відповідний професійний
стандарт зазначається назва відповідного
документу так яким затверджено
професійний стандарт наводяться
реквізити висновку суб'єкта перевірки
також реквізити висновку відповідної
профспілки галузевої які подавався
професійний стандарт на погодження також
вноситься дата внесення професійного
стандарту до реєстру професійних
стандартів тобто мається на увазі саме
до реєстру кваліфікацій і зазначається
рекомендована дата перегляду
професійного стандарту
звертаю вашу увагу Шановні колеги на
етап публічного громадського обговорення
так тому що саме на етапі публічного
громадського обговорення
заклад освіти вони
заклади освіти можуть долучатися до
змістовного наповнення проекту
професійного стандарту тобто необхідно
саме слідкувати постійно Національне
агентство кваліфікації на своєму сайті
на сайті розробники які розробляють
відповідний проект професійного
стандарту публікує що зараз відповідний
проект професійного стандарту
знаходиться на публічному громадському
обговоренні і тоді представники освітян
можуть надавати до змістової частини
проекту професійного стандарту свої
зауваження в контексті змісту тому що
коли професійний стандарт вже на
публічному громадському обговоренні був
він затверджується протоколом і йде на
перевірку тобто вже етап закритий щодо
надання пропозицій і зауважень тому коли
освітяни запрошує вас активно долучатися
саме до процесу публічного громадського
обговорення на завершення колегії мабуть
уже перебрала свій ліміт декілька слів
скажу щодо зареєстрованих професійних
стандартів Так ми розуміємо що їх
кількість зараз невелика але це
професійні стандарти які зараз є
актуальні на ринку праці щодо
ознайомлення з сайтом національного
агенства кваліфікації із реєстром
кваліфікації ви бачите посилання де
можна зайти і
передивитися професію зараз на
наступному слайді Так в нас є відомості
про заявки на розроблення професійного
стандарту Які саме в реєстрі
кваліфікації зазначаються ви бачите
заявка коли вона була
заявка коли вона надійшла так і коли
саме заявка заре єстрована і який термін
розроблення відповідної заявки хто її
розробляє чи вона скасована чи внесені
зміни до відповідної заяви і також
Шановні колеги відомості про
професійний стандарти де ви можете
ознайомитися і зрозуміти яким саме чином
які саме професійний стандарт зараз
розроблений Шановні колеги Перепрошую Да
що я перебрала мабуть ліміт свого часу
тому Дякую вам всім за увагу
Шановні колеги і передаю слово
Перепрошую пані гану трошечки зміни тим
часом не прорахувалася свої Перепрошую
вас пані Ганну до наступної презентації
це кваліфікаційні центри правовий статус
та окремі аспекти створення у нас
доповідає заступник голови Національного
агентства кваліфікації пані Ганна різнік
прошу вас пані Ганну
Дякую Людмила Миколаївна Шановні колеги
ще раз Доброго дня
бачу знайомі обличчя тож я рада всіх вас
бачити сьогодні трошки так само ми з
вами попрацюємо буду намагатись
вкластися зі своєю презентацією
Відведений час але будемо з вами
орієнтуватися в ситуації Можливо десь
буде скорочувати на візуально все рівно
будете бачити матеріал за кілька
періодів
продовження розмови Людмила Миколаївна є
сьогодні буду говорити про правові
статус кваліфікаційний центр та окремі
аспекти з тварин Анна перед тим як
перейти до демонстрації були своєї
презентації за словами традицією колеги
я перш за все хочу вам подякувати це те
що ви доєднались до нашого зустрічі за
те що у вас включені камери я завжди
говорю що завжди приємно вірш приймальне
працювати з живою в аудиторію яка тебе
слухає НВК Так вона дивиться тому за це
окремо Дякую і Хочу зазначити що
вона насправді відкритий завжди до
співпраці ми працюємо на нині в режимі
найбільшого сприяння моє сервісної
організації тож якщо у вас будуть
питання чи коли вони у вас будуть
особливо Після перегляду наших доповідей
сьогодні будь ласка звертайтеся до нас
Ми готові відповісти на всі ваші питання
в будь-якому форматі який буде зручно як
для вас так і для нас
колеги Отже відповідно до законодавства
присвоювати підтверджувати розвивати
професійну кваліфікацію це слова скажемо
так терміни які я думаю вам вже знайомі
так можете уповноваження на це суб'єкти
які ми власне є кваліфікаційним центром
і в першу чергу я хочу акцентувати увагу
на тому що система роботи з
кваліфікаційним центром вона зосереджена
в першу чергу навколо людини
нині в умовах війни коли підприємство
зазнало руйнувань багато підприємстві
всі зони про це знаємо багато випадків
Коли документи працівники можуть бути
втрачені або фактично є втрачені людина
може процедуру оцінювання
кваліфікаційному центрі отримати
сертифікат та присвоюванню підтвердження
в'язання відповідного професійної
кваліфікації і відповідно до цього може
бути праця для шторму це особливо
важливо в неї інші умови в умовах війни
і в першу чергу для цього не потрібно
подавати ніякі додаткові документи про
освіту взагалі не такі документи про
освіту подаватимуть людина звернулась
прийшла на цей момент отримала свої
результати отримала сертифікат стиль
сертифікату не пішла для школи на роботу
Насправді всі ми з вами знаємо що ці
положення вони інтегровані у Word
Перепрошую а це у нас в першу чергу
розкриває дуже багато важливих Скажімо
так особливостей і можливостей не тільки
для роботодавця а і для робітника в
першу чергу
станом на сьогодні колеги система в
умовах війни Не дивлячись на такі важкі
часи системи працює повноцінно і
насправді дуже ефективні з вашого
дозволу я трошки похвалюся тому що
станом на сьогодні у нас така знаєте
суха статистика Таном на сьогодні у нас
функціонує вже 25 кваліфікаційних
центрів і за період війни воєнного стану
у нас було присвоєно кваліфікаційними
центрами
1047 професійних кваліфікацій тобто
видані сертифікати про присвоєння
підтвердження визнання всі ці відомості
містяться в реєстрі кваліфікації Людмила
Миколаївна Сьогодні згадувала про нього
коли ви знайдете на наш сайт
Національного агентства кваліфікації
тому власне міститься вся інформація і
про професійний стандарти і про
кваліфікаційні центри до яких можна
звертатись Ну і власне про ті
сертифікати про присво єння
підтвердження визнання які видають
кваліфікаційну це колеги я виведу на
екран презентацію
так
Скажіть мені будь ласка чи видно
дякую дякую колеги буду періодично
запитувати прошу кого є можливість
відповідати
колеги говоримо сьогодні про правовий
статус окремі аспекти створення Тема
надзвичайно актуальна
кожну таку презентацію ми власне
починаємо з того що ми позначаємо
нормативно-правові акти підзаконні з
якими працює Національне агентство
кваліфікації вони тут ви бачите на
картинці вони Подивіться будь ласка
хронологічному порядку розташовані але
Певно що хочу звернути окремо вони всі
між собою насправді взаємопов'язані
Давайте звернемося до першого
нормативного порядок визнання в Україні
професійних кваліфікацій здобутих в
інших країнах це власне робота
кваліфікаційного Це далі положення про
Реєстр кваліфікацій як я тільки що
сказала реєстр кваліфікацій плюс один із
ключових елементів в роботі
кваліфікаційних центрів чому
акредитувався кваліфікаційний центр
національне агентство кваліфікації
внесло відомості в реєстр відомості
відкриті доступний путь хто бажає чи
може зайти подивитися які за якими
професійні кваліфікаціями власне
працюють той чи інший кваліфікаційний
центр Ну і власне нам подають це
відомості як я вже позначала да про які
сертифікати які видає
кваліфікаційний центр ця інформація
відкрита вона міститься в реєстрі
кваліфікації далі
про це твердження порядку присвоєння та
підтвердження професійних кваліфікацій
кваліфікаційного центру це так само
опція кваліфікаційного центру якщо ми з
вами колеги для застосую Тут така класна
штука є лазерна указка Чесно кажучи в
першу чергу перший раз нею користуюся з
повною так дивіться
порядок присвоєння підтвердження
професійних кваліфікації та І ми
повертаємося до першої визнання в
Україні професійних кваліфікацій тобто
кваліфікаційний центр у нас працює з
трьома опціями присвоєння підтвердження
і визнання професійної інваліфікації
деякі питання акредитації
кваліфікаційним центром Власне кажучи в
боботі з питань які стосуються
кваліфікаційних центрів це є основна
постанова
тому що вона визначає порядок
проходження процедури акредитації
строком на 5 років і даємо можливість
кваліфікаційному центру присвоювати
підтверджувати розвивати професійним та
відмінність Ну і так само один із
основних документів це також постанова
затвердження порядку розроблення ведення
в дію та перегляду професійної сторінки
колеги цим важливий цей документ ви
сьогодні вже почну для того щоб
функціонував кваліфікаційний центр для
того щоб він зайшов на процедура
акредитації має бути відповідний
професійний стандарт тому що
акредитується кваліфікаційний центр за
професійною кваліфікацією визначеною
професійним стандартом простіше кажучи
немає професійного стандарту На жаль
кваліфікаційний центр не буде
акредитований власне він не зможе за
певної професійною кваліфікацією якої
немає ми тому що немає у нас
професійного ста присвоювати
підтверджувати чи розвивати професію
що ж таке кваліфікаційний центр
у зв'язку також Всі ви знаєте були
оновлено частково законодавства і
безпосередньо в законі України про
освіту у нас там було позначення що це
суб’єкти тавноваження на оцінювання
визнання результатів навчання присвоєння
підтвердження відповідних та часткових
професійних кваліфікацій визнаного в
Україні працюють кандидатів здобуток по
інших країн колеги у казкою показую
червоною лазерною сподіваюсь видно
дивіться
уповноважені Зверніть увагу на
оцінювання і визнання результатів
навчання
тобто перед тим як присвоїти підтвердити
визнати професійну кваліфікацію
кваліфікаційний центр і повноважену
оцінювання і як наслідок якщо результат
позитивний визнати Результат навчання
того здобувача який до вас звернеться Ну
давайте уявимо що ви представники
кваліфікаційних центрів після цього
кваліфікаційний центр що у нас тут про
що я говорила може присвоювати
стверджувати професійну кваліфікацію так
і визнавати професійну кваліфікацію це
основний функціонал кваліфікаційного
центру
колеги ми в роботі з кваліфікаційними
центрами зазвичай орієнтуємося виключно
на норму закону дуже часто до нас
звертаються і запитують то все Хто ж так
хто ж може отримати статус
кваліфікаційного центру тут все просто
тому що ми звертаємося до постанови
знову ж таки 900
86 колеги повернусь сюди бачите деякі
питання акредитації кваліфікаційних
центрів це основна постанова яка
стосується акредитації кваліфікаційних
центрів насправді дуже раджу вам з нею
ознайомитися Якщо ви будете заходити на
акредитацію Там дуже багато цього
написано і зрозуміло для заявника тож
кваліфікаційний центр може здійснювати
свою діяльність як з юридична особа
структурний чи представлений підрозділ
юридичної особи колеги деталізувати не
буду тут знаходяться серед вас керівники
всі знаєте правда що таке структурний що
таке відокремлений підрозділ юридичної
особи Звертаю увагу на те що соком не
можуть отримати з кави з
кваліфікаційними це ми говоримо лише про
юридичну особу так Тепер давайте
повернемося чи почнемо говорити про
алгоритм створення кваліфікаційних схем
колеги Зверніть будь ласка увагу на цей
слайд У нас тут ми позначили дві опції
дві опції тому що нині станом на
сьогодні вони існують одна опція у нас
існувала крізь призму акредитації
кваліфікаційних центрів існує нині і
буде існувати далі однак із
запровадженням правового режиму воєнного
стану у нас з'явилася ще 314 постанова
Подивіться будь ласка на ліву колоночку
колеги я перепрошую лазерною указкою
навози видно те що я виділяю бачу
махаєте видно Дякую дивіться Гляньте
будь ласка сюди це у нас 314 постанова
називається Вона деякі питання
забезпечення провадження господарської
діяльності в умовах воєнного стану що
вона нам дає Ні чітко говориться про те
що період воєнного стану право на
провадження в господарської діяльності
може набуватися суб’єктами
господарювання на підставі безоплатного
подання до органів ліцензування
дозвільних органів суб'єктів надання
публічних послуг електронних послуг
декларації колеги Ось вони декларації
про впровадження господарської
діяльності
про це декларація Вона має вмістити
відомості відповідно до додатку 1 без
отримання дозвільної документів або
інших документів крім видів
господарської діяльності за переліком
згідно додатком 2 що це означає така
декларація може бути поданим в
електронній формі через єдиний державний
веб-портал електронних послуг зокрема
засобами Дія це така знаєте зараз нині
дуже актуальна історія тому що заходять
до нас документи власне з підтвердженими
витягами з портали і дія і цнапів зараз
ми про це поговоримо пів паперовій формі
можуть подаватися дитині якщо паперовій
формі вирішили подати документи то це
все відбувається через центр надання
адміністративних послуг з так звані
цнапи всі ми з вами це знаємо так і така
декларація вона продається особисто
суб'єктом моделювання або уповноваженої
особи також можна надіслати
особливість впровадження господарської
діяльності за постановою 314
особливість в тому що
законодавець визначив Що через три
місяці після
закінчення або скасування правового
режиму воєнного стану такий суб'єкт який
здійснює свою діяльність на підставі
декларації він повинен звернутися до
Національного агентство кваліфікації
протягом трьох місяців і пройти класичну
стандартну процедуру акредит колеги і
тут ми з вами дивимося на праві коли
важке і бачимо Постанову деякі питання
акредитації кваліфікаційні в це
що вона нам говорить
пам'ятаєте я на початку виберемо що
процедура акредитації якщо результат
позитивний видається сертифікат строком
на 5 років
і за постанова нам говорить про те що
заявник її реструктурний або
відокремлений підрозділ проходить
процедура акредитації за професійними
кваліфікаціями визначеними професійними
стандартами колеги ще раз акцентую на
цій опції бачите
має бути обов'язково
професійний стандарт і визначено йому
професійна кваліфікація та набуває
статусу кваліфікаційного центру з дати
прийняття агентства рішення про
кредитацію кваліфікаційного центру Я
думаю що з того що я сказала різниця для
вас очевидів правда пройти акредитацію
Ну скажімо так
і отримати сертифікат строком на 5 років
і подати декларацію але
прийти на процедуру як акредитації через
три місяці після того дискасовано
припинення правовий режим бензинового
стану а я би все-таки хотіла колеги
закцентувати увагу більше емоційним вона
у нас нині найбільш застосована
оскільки вона передбачає подачу
документів і проведення певної процедури
акредитації експертизи Я на них буду
акцентувати
Подивіться будь ласка На наступний слайд
і Зверніть будь ласка увагу що Майже
після кожного абзацу у нас позначено
презентації посилання Бачите така
Різниця фіалкова чи фіолетовий колір всі
по-різному відображається але є така
пляшка внизу такою плашкою ми позначаємо
посилання на відповідний пункт
нормативно-правового а робиться це
свідомо для того щоб всім показати що в
першу чергу для того щоб починати якось
наявність потрібно ознайомитися з
нормативно-правовими зазвичай у них дуже
детально все описано Отже
ми з вами вже проговорили те що суб'єкт
набуває статусу кваліфікаційного центру
з дати прийняття агентствам рішення про
акредитацію кваліфікаційного це
Валерій
що ж таке акредитація кваліфікаційного
центру це є певна процедура то є
визнання національним кваліфікації
заявника тобто тієї юридичної особи яка
до нас звернулася його структурного чи
відокремленого підрозділу спроможним але
здійснювати оцінювання в першу чергу та
і визнання результатів здобувачів
неформальну інформацію і за результатами
присвоєння підтвердження визнання
відповідної професійної кваліфікації
Зверніть будь ласка увагу що за його
структурний підрозділ
відокремлений підрозділ проходять
процедуру акредитації за професійними
кваліфікаціями визначеними відповідними
професійними стандартами колеги ви
помітили що я на цьому акцентую увагу
вже в третій раз це робиться свідомо для
того щоб показати оцей взаємозв'язок
професійний стандарт визначено в ньому
професійна кваліфікація якщо все в
порядку будь ласка кваліфікаційний центр
присвоює підтверджує визнає відповідно
професійну двері кваліфікацію очевидно
немає про стандарту немає професійної
кваліфікації Ну тоді кваліфікаційному
центру нижче працювати де саме це
прекрасно розуміють так тобі що ви
вигадувати професійну кваліфікацію ніхто
не отже
сама процедура акредитацій вона
проводиться за однією або декількома
професійними кваліфікаціями що віднесені
до однієї до однієї секції видів
економічної діяльності ось такими речами
працює секретаріат національного
агентства кваліфікації їх визначає Чи це
є один вид економічної діяльності чи ні
колеги вони будуть вже зачіплювати що
такий професійний стандарт цю тему вже
розглянули дуже з вашого дозволу
території
[музика]
У нас є відповідно до постанови 986
рекомендований перелік документів від
заявникам який він має нам подати для
того щоб пройти процедуру акредитації
але я трошки забігаючи наперед хочу вам
певний взаємозв'язок показати Подивіться
будь ласка я зараз прочитаю цей
документи Але Одразу я покажу наступний
слайд дивіться тут у нас слайд
називається
рекомендований перелік документів
заявлень та а наступні два слайди у нас
стосується критеріїв акредитації чому я
поки попередньо вам так переходжу і
показую тому що всі відомості які
містяться в документах які подає нам
заявник вони власне мають корелювати
цими критеріями які позначені в
постанови зрозуміли так тобто документи
мають бути сформовані таким чином щоб
забезпечити відповідність кожному
критерію акредитації Отже
колеги про що ми говоримо якщо ми
говоримо про документи які заходять на
акредитацію то тут взагалі все просто
тому що визначення чітко перелік що нам
потрібно подати копія статуту
це коли мова йде про юридичну особу
однак в разі коли статус
кваліфікаційного центру відпочинок бути
структурна чи відокремле підрозділ
заявника тут вже ми деталізуємо і нам
потрібні копії рішення копії наказів
протоколів Перепрошую органів управління
заявника про створення такого чи
відповідного структурного підприємства і
обов'язково копій положення про
структурний чи відокремленим під
областям а далі відомості про осіб
обов'язково В яких заявних залучає як
оцінювачів згідно з додатком 2 до
порядку акредитації копію трудових
цивільних правових договорів зц колеги
оцінювачі забігаючи
потрібні
кваліфікаційної центру для того щоб
оцінити також здобувача які прийде
кваліфікаційний центр звернеться з метою
присвоєння підтвердження пізнання
професійної кваліфікації так
примірник оригіналу документу що містить
виклад затвердженої заявником процедури
присвоєння підтвердження професійної
кваліфікації за кожною професійною
кваліфікацією це дуже важливий насправді
секретаря пансіонального агентства коли
отримує допомоги має право протягом 5
днів з моменту як він не зайшли офіційно
перевірити заяву документи на
комплектність тобто перевірити чи є з
того переліку вимагаю у нас постанова
986 чи є той документ далі
копії документів що підтверджують право
власності або користування приміщенням
обладнанням звіт про передачу кому це
контрольно оцінювальні матеріали
і відомості про вебсайт заявника який
забезпечить або нині вже забезпечують
публічне інформування при
кваліфікаційний центр відповідні
професійні кваліфікації та процедури
присвоєння підтверджень колеги з
довільних будь ласка увагу дужечках
міститься опція у довільній формі Ну той
же самостійно ваші керівництво Чи ви
люди які будуть готувати пакет
документів визначаєте в якій формі
покласти на папір Скажімо так ті
відомості про сайт тепер дивіться по про
що я говорила ми переходимо до критеріїв
акредитації І що ми бачимо перше
те що нам постанова говорить
спроможність заявника структурного чи
від отриманого підрозділу здійснювати
оцінювання
підтвердження визнання
визначається у ході проведення
акредитаційної експертизи про що ми з
вами починаємо говорити на початку за
такими критеріями його привітації колеги
простіше кажучи
заявник який подав документи має
забезпечити відповідність кожному із
далі перелічених критерій дивіться будь
ласка Я зачитувати повністю не буду
статут зверніть увагу бачите тобто
наявність у статуті заявника певних
відповідних положень так
особи в яких заявник або відокремлений
відокремленим структура залишає як
оцінювач
повернемось з вами до
рекомендованого переліку дивіться статут
є та відомості про осіб теж є власне
постанові форми яку потрібно
це саме стосується все і інших критеріїв
у відповідності документів давайте
подивимось Щось я повиненство так
наявність затвердженої заявником його
відокремленим підрозділом процедури
присвоєння
наявності комік контрольного
оцінювальних матеріалів для здійснення
процедури ціни наявність
матеріально-технічних ресурсів для
здійснення процедури зцілення і
обов'язково опція наявність веб-сайта
для розміщення інформації про
кваліфікаційні центри відповідні
професійні кваліфікації та процедуру
власної присвоєння підтверджень А тепер
колеги Подивіться будь ласка вниз
червоним шрифтом спеціально позначені
дуже важливі ключовий момент стосується
авін того що невідповідність хоча б
одного з критеріїв акредитації чи
невідповідність встановлюють експерти
які надбере з реєстру кваліфікацій які
там є
навіть така невідповідність є підставою
для відмови в акредитації заявника його
структурного або відокремленого це дуже
важливо в офіційній справі таку
невідповідність ми трошечки пізніше про
неї поговоримо наші експерти позначають
у своєму звіті отримали документи
працюють з ними І навпроти кожного
критерію проставляють таку опцію
відповідає не відповідає частково
відповім
якщо ми намагалися колеги для вас
трошечки візуалізувати щоб було більш
Скажімо так
краще до сприйняття давайте тепер уявимо
що ви всі представники кваліфікаційних
центрів Ну ми на зрозуміли от ви заявили
перше що робить заявник це подає заяву
із додатками до
як я вже говорила У нас є 5 днів
секретаріату на опрацювання заяви і
доданок до неї документів на
комплектність Тобто ми перевіряємо
наявність документів Назви цих
документів кількість сторінок в
комплекті далі
Національне агентство кваліфікації
призначає до своєму засіданні експертну
комісію визначає план і строки роботи
цієї експертної комісії далі Після
рішення національного агентства
кваліфікації така експертна комісія з
числа експертів які входять до нашого
реєстру кваліфікацій проходять
спеціальний відбір а їх за рішенням
національного агентства включаються в
реєстр кваліфікації
експертна комісія у нас дивіться
формується ось те що я скажу з числа
експертів які включені до реєстру
коліків
і вони у визначений строк рішенням
національного агентства проводить
акредитаційну експертизу і експертна
комісія видає висновок про відповідність
або на відповідність заявника критеріям
акредитації далі такий звіт колеги
розглядається подається Мозги на розгляд
на засідання національного університету
кваліфікації Ну і власне вже Національне
агентство кваліфікації ухвалює рішення
за результатами процедури презентації та
розгляду звіту про результати
акредитаційної експертизи на наступному
слайді я більш деталізую Зверніть будь
ласка увагу на ключові моменти сама
процедура акредитації вона проводиться
із трьох щойно перевищує 45 робочих днів
але
бувають різні випадки і
на такі на такій випадок
постановою передбачено продовження на 15
днів тому
загальні проведення процедури в
гравітації не може перевищувати 60 днів
ми маємо стандартний 45 днів і якщо
потрібно за потреби застосовуємо 50 днів
Головне що 15 днів Головне щоб загальний
строк не перевищив 60 робочих глибини а
що ж таке акредитаційна експертиза
колеги дуже трошечки деталізує це все
так бачу питання колеги я з вашого
дозволу на питання в кінці добре
відповім щоби ми не збивались що ж таке
акредитаційний експертиза заходи
спрямовані на встановлення відповідності
за невника інфраструктурні умови
відокремленими підрозділі критеріями
кандидатів чи проводяться експортну
комісією за акредитацію відповідно до
порядку акредитації перехід пенсійного
центру Подивіться будь ласка уважно що ж
в себе включає акредитаційна експертиза
говорячи простими словами це проведення
експертної комісії ви вже пам'ятаєте І
знаєте що експертна комісія то ті
експерти яких ми беремо з реєстру
кваліфікацій аналізу та оцінки заяви та
додаток до неї документів щодо
відповідності заявника його структурну
ці відокремленого підрозділу критеріями
привітації і саме ключове що нам
потрібно від акредитаційної експертизи
колеги це звіт тобто основний ключовий
елемент відкриття акредитаційної
експертизи це складення звіту про
результативної експертизи Чому Тому що
за результатами цього звіту агентство
приймає рішення у власному гарантувати
не кредитувати або відправити
неповторний інституцію
тепер коли у нашій експерти попрацювали
власне за результатами акредитаційної
експертизи така експертна комісія видає
один із виселень Що відображається у
звіті колеги Зверніть будь ласка увагу
висновок відображається щодо кожної
професійної кваліфікації окремо
виокремлюється професійна кваліфікація
на проти ставиться вислів Отже які опції
насправді дві перша опція - це
заявництво відокремлених підрозділ
відповідає критеріям акредитації
підсумком що буде Ну звичайно агентство
може прийняти рішення про акредитацію і
заявник структурних підрозділ
відокремлений не відповідає критеріям
акредитації наслідком якого висновку
може бути теж у національному мистецтві
кваліфікації відмовить в акредитації
кваліфікаційного центру не акредитують
Та
то про що я тільки що говорила за
результатами процедури акредитації
агентство ухвалює рішення окремо так
само колегу Подивіться будь ласка окремо
за кожною професійною кваліфікацію
акредитувати кваліфікаційні центри
відмовити в акредитації заявника його
структурного чи відокремленого
підрозділу Ну і проведення повторної
акредитаційної експертиз
ця опція дуже важлива
і вона функціонує повноцінну підставами
для прийняття агентствам рішення про
відмови в акредитації заявника його
структурі умови відокремленими
підрозділу є так само дві опції колеги
встановлення на підставі звуки
експертної комісійної відповідності
заявника відносно структурі вночі
відокремленого підрозділу критеріїв
матеріалізації і виявлення У поданих
взаємоком документ недостовірних
відомостей
колеги цей склад слайд короткий Я з
вашого дозволу вже не буду його
переказувати але за результатами
процедура акредитації щодо вже у нас
комплексна картинка склалася якщо
висновок позитивний якщо Національне
агентство кваліфікації приймає рішення
кредитувати кваліфікаційний центр
протягом трьох робочих днів видається
сертифікат в електронній формі і тут так
само акцентую увагу що сертифікат
видається окремо за кожну професію
що заявник зайшов в нас за одним
професійним стандартом одна наприклад за
4 професійними кваліфікаціями знак
розглядає кожне кожне професійну
кваліфікацію окремо у піцу і за кожною
професійною кваліфікацією приймає
рішення і віддає сертифікат якщо рішення
воно позитивне
та Тепер давайте вже більш практично У
нас така площина от ви отримали
сертифікат про акредитацію
кваліфікаційного центру колеги трошечка
буде тавтологія Але тим не менше я маю
вам її позначити Це з чого ми починали
Зверніть будь ласка увагу на підставі
сертифікату про акредитацію
кваліфікаційного центру кваліфікаційний
центр у нас що може робити 4 варіанту
немає у третьому ми насправді Перший
варіант здійснювати оцінювання визнання
результатів навчання здобувачів тобто я
до вас звернулася якщо я здобувач ви
маєте в мене оцінити і визнати або не
визнати результат мого навчання да для
того щоб перейти до іншого опціоналу у
нас це що
присвоювати підтверджувати визнавати
професійну кваліфікацію Якщо я до вас
звернулася
а колеги
насправді
кваліфікаційні центри мають чітко
прописану
прописаний алгоритм того як вони мають
розділяти він позначений в тих
нормативно-правових так з яких ми
починали Подивіться будь ласка Якщо
коротко виглядає це так От наприклад
дивіться давайте уявимо що я здобува
ч і для цієї це
перша опція у нас це прийняття вами
заяви про присвоєння підтвердження
професійної кваліфікації та інших
документів поданих здобувачем тобто у
першу чергу ми говоримо про те що десь у
вас на сайті мінімум має бути інформація
позначена про те в якій формі ту заяву я
вам подаю правда якщо я хочу ваш
кваліфікаційний центр звернутися
Далі ви маєте провести подолала я вам
документи Ви маєте провести зі мною
співбесіду бо я здобувач
а потім після співбесіди вищого робите
Ви приймаєте рішення щодо можливості
проведення процедури оцінювання колеги і
наступна опція - це проведення процедури
оцінювання А вони що я хочу звернути
увагу дивіться
співбесіда спочатку проводиться не або
співбесіда і проведення процедури
оцінювання це імператив маєте спочатку
зі мною поспілкуватися та провести
співбесіду
прийняти рішення зараз візуально я
покажу як це виглядає і провести
допустити мене до проведення процедури
оцінюють це обов'язково
Ну і наступний це у нас прийняття
рішення за результатами процедури
присвоєння підтвердження від видачі
відповідного документу колеги постанові
зазначено таке формулювання видача
відповідного документу але за
установленою практикою кваліфікаційні
центри за аналогією документ і називають
його сертифікат це установлена
практика
колеги для того щоб
вам було трошки
простіше і веселішими підготували таких
кольоровий слайд щоб він вже вам
візуалізувати як то буде так процедура
проходити якщо до вас звернуться з дочки
значить я вам вивела на екран слайд і у
мене є сподіваюсь у всіх де ж десь
приблизно одні якісь самі кольори
відображаються у мене жовтий відтінки
зеленого і такий теракотовий
помаранчевий колір сподіваюсь ви десь
приблизно такі самі кольори бачити тож
Подивіться будь ласка ліворуч бачите У
нас тут є здобувач у формі пряник
давайте собі уявимо що це я різні Ганна
Олегівна от я звертаюся в
кваліфікаційний центр так хочу щоб ви
мені присвоїли підтвердили чи визнали
якусь відповідну професійну кваліфікацію
перше на що я Звертаю увагу
строк процедури присвоєння підтвердження
не повинен перевищувати 25 днів
пам'ятаєте ми говорили що акредитація
кваліфікаційного центру відбувається
протягом 45 днів плюс 15 тобто межа 60
днів
кваліфікаційний центр же ж натомість
працює в межах визначених 20-ти днів
тепер дивіться У вас є 25 днів Як ви їх
там розіб'єте то вже ваша справа то у
ваших внутрішніх документах буде
позначено що на що Скільки днів ви
відведете що це означає приклад вам
надали дивіться
звернулася до вас різні Ганна подала всі
документи я зайшла на ваш сайт Да ви там
висвітлили всю інформацію все зрозуміло
Я скачала заяви подивилася які вимоги чи
потрібні ще якісь опції подала вам
документ тепер дивіться
перевірка
кваліфікаційним центром протягом 10
робочих днів заяви та доданих документів
і проведення співбесіду
Подивіться будь ласка уважно 10 днів
вдається на перевірку заяви і в ці ж 10
днів входить така опція як проведення зі
мною з співбесіди 10 днів є Але ви тут
самостійно визначаєте яким чином ви на
дні їх розбиваєте тут вже відповідно до
особливостей вашої роботи Отже прийняли
мої документи подивилися давайте уявимо
що все в порядку з документами Да
ви провели зі мною співбесіду я
з'явилася Ну я припускаю колеги що
скоріш за все не телефонним зв'язком ви
в мене будете повідомляти да А за
правилами діловодства це припускаю я ви
щоби йому скоріш за все надішлете мені
офіційного листа правда на ту адресу
електронної поштою яка буде позначена в
моїй заяві
значить що далі відбувається Я з'явилася
пройшла співбесіду ви зрозуміли
перевірили Ми там якісь документи заяви
мій підпис підтвердили самі для себе що
я можу далі рухатися і працювати з вами
і що у нас далі йде за результатами
співбесіди протягом трьох робочих днів
кваліфікаційний центр повідомляє мене
про що давайте подивимось Ви маєте
Зверніть увагу що форма повідомлення
вона не визначена постанові але знаючи
правила діловодства очевидно що скоріше
за все це буде офіційний лист і це буде
супроводжуватися ще якимось дзвінком
щоби Як то сказати вже точно буде
впевненим що я з'явлюсь та і не забуду
з'явитися кваліфікаційний центр для
проходження процедури оцінювання отже
повідомляйте ви мене письмово про що Ну
якщо щось не так із моїми документами ви
повідомляєте мене про відмову
обґрунтовану проведені процедури
оцінювання
дуже часто наші слухачі запитують що
означає ґрунтована відмова для цього
вона потрібна тут Насправді все Очевидно
це як ЗИС з питаннями обґрунтована
відмова має бути для того щоб на випадок
коли мені щось не сподобається я подам
апеляцію правда колеги Ну і буду
говорити що ви були суб'єктивні щоб ви
мали можливість мені пояснити чому ви
обрали таку опцію Якщо ж все в порядку
колеги дивимося з вами на ліву плашку
зеленого кольору ви визначаєте час дату
місце та умови проведення процедури
оцінюємо
власне за результатами проведених
процедура оцінювання
Полісся яку ви створюєте своїми
документами оцінювання ухвалює рішення
Що відображається у протоколі про
тут так само колеги Зверніть будь ласка
увагу Подивіться праворуч тут насправді
два функціоналу дві опції перше цей
відмова мені присвоєнні підтвердження
повної часткової кваліфікацією такі
підстави для відмови від прописані у вас
у наших внутрішніх документах щоби
різних Ганна Олегівна коли у вас
питається чи ваше оцінювачів в цьому
справа Чому не так сталося ну
обґрунтовано ваше співробітники вашого
оцінювачів могли надати пояснення
скажімо це дуже важливо і друге якщо все
в порядку визнання результатів навчання
різні Ганни присвоєння підтвердження
меню повної часткової професійної валюжі
якщо все в порядку і я прийшла позитивно
Скажімо так процедуру оцінюють
далі
до наступного функціоналу це у нас
плашка житлового кольору яка нам
говорить про те що на підставі рішення
комісії затвердженого Так це тобто є
Рішення комісії має бути затверджують
кваліфікаційний центр Ви як
кваліфікаційні центри протягом 5 робочих
днів маєте видати мені
два умовних документа якщо для мене все
пройшло погано і я не прийшла наприклад
завалила Ну давайте іспит оцінювання не
можуть тут коментувати бо не знаю в якій
формі де ти оцінювання будете проходити
Ну наприклад не підтвердила я
спроможність здійснювати виконувати
певний функціонал за певний професійним
тарифікацію і що ми тут бачимо ми з вами
бачимо що ви маєте нові відео таку
інформувати
рішенням про відмову мені різних гальм
легін у присвоєнні підтвердженні повної
часткової
колеги Якщо ж все пройшло в порядку
я підтвердила на процедурі оцінювання що
я можу Скажімо так бути і працювати за
певною професійною кваліфікацією ви
видаєте сертифікат про присвоєнні
підтвердження професійної
саме стосується як бізнес тепер колеги
остання У нас опція пам'ятайте я на
початку говорила що у нас все підв'язано
під реєстр кваліфікацій так
кваліфікаційні центри реєстр
кваліфікації експерти в реєстр
кваліфікацій і я говорила про те що
кваліфікаційний центр який присвоїв
підтвердив визнав професійну
кваліфікацію має подати національного
агресор кваліфікації відомості для того
щоб їх внесли в реєстр кандидатів тож
коли ви мені видали сертифікат
наші постанови говорять про те що до 20
числа кожного місяця Ви маєте
прозвітувати національним агентствольну
презентацію надати відданість
які ж колеги відомості Ви маєте надати
як ті які вносяться в реєстр
кваліфікації прискорення підтвердження
без змінилося служба кваліфікації
Подивіться будь ласка це у нас така
велика остання плашка що тут давайте
собі
пофантазуємо назва документу сертифікат
номер документу Ну давайте CO мій рік
народження
1983 прізвище власне ім'я по-батькові
різні Ганна Олегівна Я прийшла процедура
оцінювання мені ви даєте сертифікат
назву професійної кваліфікації колеги
подобається дуже мені кухар третього
розряду якщо ви не заперечуєте давайте
уявимо що ви мені видали сертифікат про
присвоєння підтвердження наприклад
професійної кваліфікації кухар третього
розряду Ну і назва звичайно
кваліфікаційного Центру до якого Я
звернулася з яким я працювала і який
видав мені цей сертифікат про прис
підтвердження визнання професійної
кваліфікації коли я вам дякую за увагу
намагалась трошечки скорочувати в умовах
обмеженого часу а ще раз наголошу на
тому що якщо у вас будуть якісь питання
будь ласка до нас звертайтеся ми
організуємо додаткові Скажімо так
зустрічі для того щоб змістовно не
просто дати відповіді на всі ваші
питання розберемо нюанси роботи
кваліфікаційних центрів
передаю слово Людмилі миколаївні які ми
колезі колеги Дякуємо дуже за увагу
Дякуємо пані гану за таку досить
змістовну доповідь вашу оскільки Шановні
колеги більш детально пані зупинилася
саме на процедурі акредитації
кваліфікаційних центрів так і звернула
увагу на таких 6 основних
нормативно-правових актів які зараз
діють у сфері кваліфікації Дякуємо пані
Ганно наш ліміт часу Шановні колеги вже
вичерпано але ми найдемо ще 5-10 хвилин
для того Якщо у вас є питання ми надамо
зараз відповіді на зазначені питання
перед тим якщо можливо ви будете
формувати своє питання Я користуючись
нагодою хотіла Шановні колеги нагадати
що Національне агентство кваліфікації
по-друге вже проводить курс від лекцій
на тему розроблення професійних
стандартів за підсумками зазначеного
курсу відеолекцій учасники
опановують базові знання та вміння щодо
процедури і саме методичних підходів до
розроблення відповідних професійних
стандартів тому Шановні колеги учасники
сьогоднішнього вебінару Я запрошую вас
до участі в наступному курсі відеолекції
які ми плануємо проводити
щодо анонсу зазначеної події то прошу
тоді звертати у вашу увагу заходити на
сайт Національного агентства
кваліфікації і на сторінку у Facebook де
буде розміщена подія яка буде
відбуватися що для курсу відеолекцій по
завершенню курсу від алекції учасники
проводять проходять тестування і після
підбиття уже підсумків тестування
національне агенство кваліфікації надає
сертифікати Так що будемо раді бачити
сьогоднішніх учасників саме на курсі
відео лекції що стосується розроблення
професійних стандартів тому що Так більш
докладніше нас 8 я лекцій які більш
вдосконаліші змістовніше
по змісту і велика велике проміжок часу
так тому що сьогодні в 30-40 хвилин
викласти весь матеріал Я думаю мені і
Пані Гані було досить важко так тому що
ми зорієнтували увагу на такі основні
ключові моменти але якщо у вас є бажання
доєднатися чи до розроблення курсу від
лекції професійних стандартів Чи пані
Ганна веде саме курс щодо навчання
експертів то Просимо Вас доєднуватися
слідкувати за нашим сайтом тому прошу
колеги якщо є питання до нас Ми радість
пані Ганною вам відповісти і надати на
них відповіді
я бачу в чаті написали нам що нам надає
спрощена процедура відкриття
кваліфікаційного центру за постановою
314 пані Ган Я так розумію це питання до
вас прошу Так колеги я з вашого дозволу
відкоментуємо колеги я буду коментувати
дуже коротко я вже побачила в чаті є
питання як мінімум є питання які нам
потрібно проговорювати мінімум хвилин 20
Тому ще раз я наголошую подзвоніть нам
зверніться до нас і ми на такі Скажімо
так змістовні питання дамо більш
детальні відповіді Отже 314 постанова
Дивіться якщо 986 вона передбачає
подання до Національного агентства
кваліфікації заяви поданих до неї
поданих до неї документів і проходження
процедури акредитації так то 314 дає
можливість звернутись до знаку або
оформити відповідний спочатку дії і з
відповідними додатками повідомити нас
про це почати здійснювати Свою
діяльність з присвоєння підтвердження
визнання але я наголошую на тому що
протягом трьох місяців після того як
буде скасовано чи припинено правовий
режим воєнного стану такі суб’єкт
господарювання всерівно зобов'язаний
може не може зобов'язаний це імператив
звернутися до Національного агентства
кваліфікації і пройти повноцінну
процедуру акредитації відповідно до
приписів 986 постанови те то на початку
на що я акцентувала увагу де
прописується порядок акредитації
кваліфікаційних центрів
сподіваюсь дала відповідь на ваше
питання
так я і Людмила Миколаївна якщо
дозволите я в чаті бачу питання можу
сама зачитувати якщо ви не заперечуєте
пані Наталя піднімала руку Можливо в неї
є ще питання чи все добре дякую прошу чи
може заклад
педаго який відокремленою структурним
підрозділом закладу вищої освіти
створювати кваліфікаційний центр колеги
звичайно може ми відштовхуємось від
опції юридична особа структурний
відокремлений підрозділ структурний це у
нас що ну відповідно до структури вона
усіх різна да це може бути відділ
управління
якщо ми говоримо про відокремлений
підрозділ це у нас що може бути філія
представлеництво да вам потрібно
подивитись свою структуру і Подивитись
хто там в якій статус має структурний Чи
є у вас відокремлені підрозділи Головне
щоб воно йшла про юридичну особу
юридична особа кома структурний відо
заземлений підрозділ коли так наступне
питання
наявність чи можливо пояснити А пані
Наталя задала питання Так я перепрошу
пані та енергетичність перестрибнули
пані Наталя задала питання так
Чи можливо пояснити наявність
затвердженої заявникам процедури
присвоєння підтвердження професійних
кваліфікацій значить колеги це один із
основних і дуже важливих документів які
в якій визначає основну роботу основний
функціонал кваліфікаційного центру
відповідно до переліку документів і тих
критеріїв акредитацій про які ми
сьогодні з вами говорили Він має
обов'язково долучатись до заяви
додаватись із заяву що це означає А
простіше кажучи Зараз спробую простіше
кажучи знаєте як є положення про
структурні відокремлені підрозділи так
які визначають що той чи наприклад
навчальні центри чим він займається його
функціонал хто туди входить і так далі
для того щоб ви прописати таке положення
тобто процедура присвоєння підтвердження
визнання яким чином вона відбувається
треба продивитись ті всі
нормативно-правові документи на яких я
сьогодні починала свою презентацію І в
постанові Кабінету Міністрів України яка
стосується присвоєння підтвердження
професійних кваліфікацій там чітко
зазначається алгоритм яким чином має
діяти і функціонувати
кваліфікаційний центр тобто для того щоб
такий документ прописати ну тобто
процедура присвоєння підтвердження
обов'язково потрібно відкрити цей
документ ознайомитися і подивитися що що
з того що там позначено опціонально ви
враховуючи колеги зверніть увагу
враховуючи свою організаційну правову
форму так юридична особа публічного
права юридична особа приватного права
Всі ми знаємо що юридичні особи
публічного права мають ще і батьків а
навіть дуже часто органи управління
правда колеги з якими потрібно все
абсолютно погоджувати тобто враховуючи
такі нюанси враховуючи такі особливості
ви дивитеся що ви можете з тих положень
взяти і копіпастом вибачте вже за таку
прямолінійність Скажімо так позначити в
своїх документах в своїй процедурі
пам'ятаєте я вам показувала такий
Останній слайд процедура присвоєння
підтвердження там де був пряничок
імбирний Да там де ми говорили що різні
в Ганно звернулись до вас як здобувач бо
це є процедура присвоєння підтвердження
від подачі заяви мною так в якій формі
до серединки доходимо яким чином ви
будете в мене оцінювати кутом буде
входити в комісію І що я отримую на
виході в кінці цієї процедури присвоєння
підтвердження якщо для мене буде
негативний результат ми вже з вами
з'ясували це відмова повідомлення Да ви
мене інформуєте якщо це буде позити
результат Ви маєте прописати який
документ ви мені видаєте це має бути
сертифікат колеги підказую в цій
постанові яка стосується порядку
присвоєння підтвердження професійних
кваліфікацій Навіть є Скажімо так
вказівка рекомендація щодо того які має
бути сертифікат який ваші кваліфікаційні
центри будуть видавати тобто опціонально
що ви там обов'язково маєте позначити
різних Ганну Олегівна рік народження
1983-й назва свого кваліфікаційного
центру І власне рішення яким ви прийняли
наприклад
рішення про присвоєння підтвердження або
визнання мені професійної кваліфікації і
обов'язково і функціонал колеги опціонал
вірніше це у нас що позначення в
сертифікації професійної кваліфікації
власне за якою я до вас звернулася Да ми
говорили сьогодні з вами про кухаря
третього розряду і я плавно з вашого
дозволу перейду якраз до іншого питання
яке тут так само стосується цієї
процедури пояснити наявність оцінювача
відповідної професійної кваліфікації
коли простіше кажучи Коли ви будете
формувати комісію з оцінювання два
оцінювачі на одну професійну
кваліфікацію я зайшла до вас із лікарем
третього розряду мінімум має бути два
оцінювачі та рівень їхньої кваліфікації
може бути такий як у мене тобто з цієї
відповідний який професійній
кваліфікації з якою я до вас зайшла
звернулась може бути вищий але в жодному
разі не нижчий тому що за визначенням
фахівець оцінювач у вашому випадку який
має професійну кваліфікацію нижчу ніж та
за якою до вас звернулася я ну очевидно
він не може оцінити рівень моїх знань
вмінь навичок відповідної відповідність
там трудо вим функціям і так далі або
такі як у мене повторююся або вище це
зрозуміти тут вже керівництво самостійно
підбирає
оцінювачів для проведення і впровадження
здійснення процедур
присвоєння підтвердження
визнання професійних кваліфікацій
так
з Ютуба просять дати посилання на
телефони для зв’язку можливо посилання
на презентацію коли всі презентації
можемо надіслати телефон будь ласка
телефонуйте передресують все рівно всі
зв'язки або на Людмили Миколаївну або на
мене втік питань які сьогодні розглядали
ми до ваших послуг готові дати відповіді
на всі ваші питання в той момент Як ви
звернетеся Дякую колеги
дякую пані гану за змістовні такі
запитання оскільки досить багато освітян
Так саме турбує питання щодо
відповідно проходження процесу
акредитації кваліфікаційних центрів
тому Шановні колеги звертаю вашу увагу
на актуальності зазначеного проходження
нашого вебінару Оскільки ми розуміємо
чітко зараз що саме вітер професійного
стандарту в якому закладається чітко
прописується результати навчання
формується освітня програма так Яка теж
робить акцент на результати навчання і
тому між запитом роботодавцем і освітній
процесом є оцей професійний стандарт на
основі якого має саме формуватися
освітня програма тому ще раз наголошую
Шановні колеги Що ми ще раді будемо вас
бачити на нашому курсі відео лекції з
розроблення професійних стандартів і
також долучайтеся до групи експертів яке
проводить навчання Національне агентство
кваліфікації Я щиро вам дякую усім за
участь бачу активна участь тому що
досить поставлено багато питань є
питання на які наші відді витрату
опрацює і вам надасть зазначені питання
тобто ми є відкриті ми готові до
спілкування виникають питання
надавайте їх будь ласка так розумію пані
Наталя координує зазначений захід
надсилайте їй запитання ми вже робочому
порядку тоді в письмовому вигляді надамо
вам ці питання Або можливо проведемо
вебінар де ми вас залучимо і ви
отримаєте повне аспект відповіді на ті
питання які сьогодні піднімалися Дякую
всім учасникам Бережіть себе та своїх
близьких На все добре Шановні колеги до
наступних зустрічей
Дякуємо колеги